[Music]
hi conan o'brien here
just talking tonight about a bunch of
things i'm really excited about
neutron movie looks killer
i love that i get to see the old jeff
bridges and the young jeff bridges in 3d
at the same time which is really cool um
i played angry birds last night for like
seven straight hours
i made up a new drink it's half you who
have chocolate milk so it tastes just
like chocolate milk but not quite as
chocolatey as it should be
can't believe bristol pamela lost on
dancing with the stars
that was just screwed up
tired now i have time for a new segment
i'm going to do here on my video blog
it's called looking good joy lawrence
this is where i look through us
magazines and in touch
magazines and i look for any picture at
all of joey lawrence that i can find
i finally found this one i think he's at
an outback steakhouse
but anyway looking good joy lawrence um
are you still doing your video blog andy
get out of here from my room it's
private got your room at your doctor's
session get out private get out
sleepy alone
now it's time for segment called now
that's what i'm talking about this is a
fun segment where we
get out
you guys
hi internet